The next RAID technique is RAID 1,
which uses a technique called
mirroring to improve reliability.
So really,
RAID 1 puts the same data on both disks.
If we had only one disk,
we would keep the data on it.
With the other disk,
it's just a copy of the first disk.
So a write of the data from the system
will cause a write to each disk.
Now note that this results in the same
write performance as when we had one
disk alone because all of
the two writes are happening.
They're happening at the same time.
Each disk is given the same write,
so each disc does
exactly what the single disc would be
doing, as far as writes are concerned.
So this write takes approximately
the same time as it would take to do it
on one disc, because they are really
doing it simultaneously, but
for reads, we can read any one disk.
Both of them have the same data.
We only need to read the data once.
So we end up reading
only one of the disks.
So for reads, we get twice
the throughput of one disk alone.
Pretty much if we have
more than one read to do,
we're going to send half the reads
to one disk and half to the other.
They have the identical data so
actually we can always split the disks.
We never have the situation that all
the data we want is on one disk because
really, any data can be read
from any of the two disks.
And this scheme can tolerate any
faults that affect one of the disks.
So, it could be that for example,
there's a bad sector on one disk.
Well, we can just read the same
data from the other disk.
Or we can have an entire disk fail,
in which case we are left with one
disk that still has all the data.
So remember when we said that we
have two copies of something, and
we can detect, but
not correct the error.
For disks this is not true,
because the ECC
on each sector of each of the disks
will detect errors that occur already.
So now that we know
which one has an error,
we can always use the other one
that doesn't have an error there.
So if you have two copies of something
and you know which copy is wrong, then
you can, of course, correct the error
simply by reading the correct copy.